frozen wand enough hearts the critics
and young audiences alike just couldn't
seem to let it go
luckily for Disney it looks like critics
are mostly feeling the same way about
the film's upcoming sequel frozen to the
long anticipated follow-up to what was
once the highest-grossing animated movie
of all time
had its star-studded premiere in Los
Angeles on Thursday November 7th a movie
six years in the making
the latest enchanting adventure of
sisters Anna and The Snow Queen Elsa saw
Hollywood creatives and entertainment
critics come out in droves to get the
first look at the film wall-e enchanting
fantasy flick which follows the sisters
are saying their friends travel far from
the kingdom of arendelle to find the
source of Elsa's powers it's in slated
for release until November 22nd critics
and attendants have already taken to
social media to share their initial
reactions and it all seems to point to
yet another animated head for Disney the
general consensus from those with
premiere invites pointing to a follow-up
that's creatively competitive with the
original a film that quickly became both
an award-winning animated classic and
pop culture phenomenon frozen to songs
and visuals especially have received
considerable praise Mashable Deputy
entertainment editor NGJ Han acknowledge
that the frozen sequel exists in part
simply because of the financial success
of the first film
still han said that doesn't take away
from what the second installment does
right among these things are new songs
and an adorable new character Jason guru
Co Business Insider's senior
entertainment reporter called frozen to
a worthy sequel that offers up some
truly amazing animation he added Elsa
writes of water horse and it's
breathtaking the song into the unknown
is primed to be let it go like addictive
sorry parents when the social embargo
for frozen to lifted after the film
screening critic Clayton Davis took to
Twitter and shed how profoundly impacted
he was by the film's messages
particularly as a father watching with
his daughter
frozen - embarks is not just an
evolution of its characters but it
sincerely acknowledges that its fanbase
has grown over the last six years and
they have new things to learn in a
changing world
songs are plentiful beautiful shots at
times it was something I really needed
it's a level of emotional resonance
Alicia Grasso an editorial leader Adam
tickets said actually brought her to
tears
both of
emotional reaction was to to the films
focus on female empowerment for which
the original was also praised she
tweeted after seeing the film frozen to
is breathtakingly beautiful and leans in
on empowerment for his characters I
cried at least three times from the
story to the last thread on Elsa's dress
the care and love put into it shows and
good news everyone of team Elsa gets at
least one so though this time around I
may cry oh I won't judge the dissing
siders editor-in-chief Scylla Shula when
perhaps the farthest of any other
journalists proclaiming that the Elsa
Anna Kristoff Olaf and Sven reunion was
better than the record smashing frozen
shoes are even provided a warning for
parents who are still getting over the
infectious love of let it go I can't
believe I'm saying this but frozen two
is better than its predecessor darker a
little more mature but still an
excellent film for families the songs
believe it or not are catchy er so
parents beware still some critics have
noted that frozen twos cloths and other
elements simply don't stand up to those
of its predecessor although they don't
have a completely flipped opinion wait
what am I looking at right now why are
you hanging off the earth like a bat
among the critics who have been well
more critical of frozen - is Alison
Foreman another Mashable reporter and
attendance at the premiere
Foreman gave the film props displace it
not having the same magic of the first
movie at least in her eyes just got Elsa
frozen - it doesn't capture the magic of
the first but it's got Elsa in a wet
suit Anna ugly crying its van ugly
crying
Kristoff singing a nineties rock ballad
Olaf at his wisest and this good boy we
must protect him at all costs but
critics like Scott Menzel the
editor-in-chief of we live entertainment
frozen - couldn't quite reach the
quality delivery of the 2013 movie
frozen
- loses some of the magic of the
original but its soundtrack is
surprisingly superior Kristoff Sven and
Olaf standouts even though the script
leaves Anna and Elsa out in the cold it
is a decent sequel but definitely a step
down from the first Ashley Menzel whose
parts of the Los Angeles Online Film
Critics Society echoed those feelings
stating that the animated productions
shifted its target demographic
actually hurts the movie frozen -
creates musical magic but story-wise
doesn't quite reach the level of the
original Oh
is certainly the highlight of the film
and brings much-needed levity to a
pretty dark film it feels like it is for
a much older crowd than the target demo
that's a rough business to be in right
now I mean that is really mmm that's
unfortunate
still almost all the reviews find
something to praise about the film and
it sounds like Disney just might have
another billion dollar box-office smash
on its hands check out one of our newest
videos right here Plus even more looper
videos but your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]